c'est un objectif affiché depuis la
révolution de maidan en 2014 et la chute
du pouvoir pro russe en ukraine
aujourd'hui kiev se rapproche un peu
plus d'une adhésion à l'union européenne
de la commission recommande au conseil
européen
premièrement de donner à l'ukraine une
perspective européenne et deuxièmement
de lui accorder le statut de candidat
ceci bien entendu à condition que le
pays procède à un certain nombre
d'autres réformes importantes
un soutien de la commission plus sial
pour l'ukraine qui ambitionne d'obtenir
un statut de candidat officiel dans
cette première étape importante kiev
peut également compter sur l'appui de la
france l'allemagne l'italie ou encore la
roumaine notre pays est prêt à faire
tout ce qui est nécessaire pour devenir
un membre à part entière de l'union
européenne tout le peuple ukrainien
partage cette ambition
l'avis consultatif de la commission
permettra aux 27 membres de l'union
européenne d'aborder la question d'une
adhésion lors d'un sommet prévu le 23
jours toute décision devra alors être
prises à l'unanimité
certains pays dont les pays-bas le
danemark et la belgique ont émis des
réserves sur la candidature de kef et
bien que la france soutienne cette
candidature emmanuel macron prévient le
chemin vers une adhésion complète
pourrait prendre des années oui nous
sommes prêts maintenant à vous
reconnaître ce statut de candidat à
l'adhésion mais nous leur avons dit tous
ensemble avec la même franchise ce
processus va prendre du temps et donc
vous ne serez pas membre demain de
l'union européenne kiev devra donc mener
des réformes profondes pour satisfaire à
l'ensemble des critères d'adhésion parmi
les conditions d'entrée à l'union
européenne avoir une démocratie et un
marché intérieur stable respecter les
droits de l'homme l'égalité des sexes et
protéger les minorités de son pays à
titre de comparaison la pologne au passé
communiste semblable à celui de
l'ukraine avait attendu dix ans entre le
dépôt de sa candidature et son entrée
officielle dans l'union en 2004